des livres il y aura ce que j'aime bien
lire mes enfants et puis des jeux de
construction playmobil barbie mais
surtout légaux ces noms reviennent
souvent parmi les demandes des clients
dans les magasins de jouets les
enseignes attendait la période des fêtes
de pied ferme pour attraper une année
compliquée vous avez les franchises qui
fonctionne bien comme lego mario comme
star wars qui fonctionne toujours très
bien où harry potter mais on a des
gammes propre à lego avec toute la gamme
city qui est donc l'organisation de la
ville des pompiers des aéroports de la
police qui fonctionne aussi toujours
très très bien c'est que le classicisme
qui reprend les valeurs sûres
du classique donc tels que le monopoly
le cluedo et autres jeux de société
une catégorie qui a beaucoup de succès
grâce aux habitudes prises par les
français pendant le confinement
on a également des jeux de la société à
ce mode et qui est basé à guyancourt
donc nous faisons dans la proximité
beaucoup de jeu d'escabeaux game 2
denquête policière de
découverte de trésors de choses comme ça
pas de souci pour les retardataires les
rayons sont pleins et prêt à supporter
les demandes de chacun une bonne
nouvelle pour les enfants également
qu'ils ne seront pas oubliés au pied du
sapin il va y avoir des jouets parce que
après l'année quand même très
particulière que tout le monde a vécu à
cause de la pandémie
les enfants seront probablement très
gâtés au pied du sapin les magasins de
jouets sont donc de retour
il mise beaucoup sur l'activité de noël
représentant 65% du chiffre d'affaires
de l'année